- [Instructor] Musa is
interested in the relationship
between hours spent studying
and caffeine consumption
among students at his school.
He randomly selects 20
students at his school
and records their caffeine
intake in milligrams
and the amount of time
studying in a given week.
Here is a computer output
from a least-squares regression
analysis on his sample.
Assume that all conditions
for inference have been met.
What is the 95% confidence interval
for the slope of the
least-squares regression line?
So if you feel inspired, pause the video
and see if you can have a go at it.
Otherwise, we'll do this together.
Okay, so let's first remind
ourselves what's even going on.
So let's visualize the regression.
So our horizontal axis, or our x-axis,
that would be our caffeine
intake
in milligrams.
And then our y-axis, or our vertical axis,
that would be the,
I would assume it's in hours.
So time
time studying.
And Musa here,
he randomly selects 20 students.
And so for each of those students,
he sees how much caffeine they consumed
and how much time they spent studying
and plots them here.
And so there'll be 20 data points.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
He inputs these data
points into a computer.
In order to fit a
least-squares regression line.
And let's say the
least-squares regression line
looks something like this.
And a least-squares regression line
comes from trying to
minimize the square distance
between the line
and all of these points.
And then this is giving us information
on that least-squares regression line.
And the most valuable things here,
if we really wanna help
visualize or understand the line
is what we get in this column.
The constant coefficient
tells us essentially
what is the y-intercept here.
So 2.544.
And then the coefficient on the caffeine,
this is, one way of thinking about,
well for every incremental
increase in caffeine,
how much does the time studying increase?
Or you might recognize this as the slope
of the least-squares regression line.
So this is
the slope
and this would be equal to 0.164.
Now this information right over here,
it tells us how well our
least-squares regression line
fits the data.
R-squared, you might
already be familiar with,
it says how much of the
variance in the y variable
is explainable by the x variable.
If it was one or 100%,
that means all of it could be explained.
And it's a very good fit.
If it was zero, that means
none of it can be explained,
and it'd be a very bad fit.
Capital S, this is the standard
deviation of the residuals.
And it's another measure of
how much these data points vary
from this regression line.
Now this column right over here
is going to prove to be useful
for answering the question at hand.
This gives us the standard
error of the coefficient.
And the coefficient that
we really care about,
the statistic that we really care about
is the slope of the regression line.
And this gives us the standard error
for the slope of the regression line.
You could view this as the estimate
of the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the slope of the regression line.
Remember, we took a
sample of 20 folks here,
and we calculated a statistic
which is the slope of the regression line.
Every time you do a different sample,
you will likely get a different slope.
And this slope is an estimate
of some true parameter in the population.
This would sometimes also
be called the standard error
of the slope of the
least-squares regression line.
Now these last two columns,
you don't have to worry about
in the context of this video.
This is useful if you were saying
well, assuming that
there is no relationship
between caffeine intake and time studying,
what is the associated T statistic
for the statistics that
I actually calculated
and what would be the probability
of getting something that
extreme or more extreme
assuming that there is no association.
Assuming that for example,
the actual slope of the
regression line is zero.
And this says, well the probability,
if we would assume that,
is actually quite low.
It's about a 1% chance
that you would've gotten these results
if there truly was not a relationship
between caffeine intake and time studying.
But with all of that out of the way,
let's actually answer the question.
Well, to construct a confidence
interval around a statistic,
you would take the value of the statistic
that you calculated from your sample.
So 0.164
and then it would be plus
or minus a critical t value
and then this would be driven by the fact
that you care about a
95% confidence interval
and by the degrees of freedom,
and I'll talk about that in a second.
And then you would multiply that
times the standard error of the statistic.
And in this case, the
statistic that we care about
is the slope.
And so this is 0.057.
Times 0.057.
And the reason why we're
using a critical t value
instead of a critical z value
is because our standard
error of the statistic
is an estimate.
We don't actually know
the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution.
So the last thing we
have to do is figure out
what is this critical t value.
You can figure it out
using either a calculator
or using a table.
I'll do it using a table.
And to do that we need to know
what the degrees of freedom.
Well, when you're doing this
with a regression slope,
like we're doing right now,
your degrees of freedom are going to be
the number of data points
you have minus two.
So our degrees of freedom
are gonna be 20 minus two.
Which is equal to 18.
I'm not gonna go into a
bunch of depth right now.
It actually is beyond the
scope of this video for sure,
as to why you subtract two here.
But just so that we can
look it up on a table,
this is our degrees of freedom.
So we care about a 95% confidence level.
That's equivalent to having
a 2 1/2% tail on either side.
And our degrees of freedom is 18.
So our critical t value is 2.101.
And so, our 95% confidence interval
is going to be 0.164 plus or
minus our critical t value
2.101 times the standard
error of the statistic.
Times,
I'll just put it in parentheses, 0.057.
And you could type this into a calculator
if you wanted to figure
out the exact values here.
But the way to interpret
a 95% confidence interval
is that 95% of the time,
that you calculated 95%
confidence interval,
it is going to overlap with the true value
of the parameter that we are estimating.